{\rtf1\ansi\ansicpg1252\cocoartf1038\cocoasubrtf360
\margl1440\margr1440\vieww10900\viewh12040\viewkind0
\pard\tx720\tx1440\tx2160\tx2880\tx3600\tx4320\tx5040\tx5760\tx6480\tx7200\tx7920\tx8640\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\f0\fs24 \cf0 I rarely even eat pad Thai in
Bangkok normally, mainly because there are
just so many other things to eat. But this
is a really special pad Thai restaurant, and
I can't wait to try this food.\
\
Pad Thai is perhaps the most widely recognized
Thai dish in the entire world, and if you're
in Bangkok, a visit to Pad Thai Pratu Pee
is a must. Here, pad Thai is taken extremely
seriously.\
\
Big meaty shrimp are first seared in hot oil
before handfuls of Thai dry rice noodles are
added to the large sized woks.\
\
Oil and generous spoonfuls of special tasty
sauces are tossed into the noodles as they
start to rehydrate over the flaming coals.
From there, it's clickity clack as the cook
works the noodles like a magician playing
with fire.\
\
Bits of tofu, and other ingredients according
to what has been ordered, are all added to
the mess of pad thai that's artfully being
created.\
\
When the noodles have reached a certain softness,
they're pushed to the side to make way for
eggs which are cracked into the wok and ready
to take on the brutal flames. The eggs and
noodles are mingled together in a sweet harmony
of complimentary flavors.\
\
When the cook feels the pad thai is ready,
the entire wok is ushered to the serving table
where the pile is divvied onto individual
plates or packed into styrofoam to-go containers.\
\
Depending on what the customer ordered, the
piping hot plates of pad thai are either served
as is, or brought over to what I like to call
the grift wrapping station.\
\
It begins with a smaller sized wok that sits
over a dangerously hot bon fire. A ladle of
beaten egg is thinly layered into the wok
as it instantly cooks through. A fresh plate
of pad thai is then dumped into the middle
of the egg, wrapped up like a present, and
flopped back onto the plate. The process is
repeated one more time so each plate of pad
thai is double wrapped in smoky eggy deliciousness.\
\
Garnish it with fresh peanuts, and gotta have
my chili, gotta have a squeeze of lime when
you eat pad thai. \
\
It's wrapped in an egg, so it's like a little
gift of pad thai, that's really good, that's
awesome. It has a nice smokey flavor. Check
out the size of these meaty shrimps. \
\
This one is called pad Thai sen jan man goong,
and what it is, as you can see it's nicely
orangey red in color. The ingredient that
makes it this color is the head juice from
big jumbo shrimp called man goong, and I don't
even know what it's called in English. Let's
see how this tastes. It's a little bit sweet,
but you can taste that shirmpiness to it,
that's awesome. \
\
If you like pad thai, you definitely have
to check this place out when you're in Bangkok.
I just finished those two plates of pad thai
and I'm stuffed right now, and I think because
I ate with such enthusiasm, they gave me a
free sticker, pretty cool huh. But anyway,
if you come to Bangkok if you like pad thai,
this is your spot.}